[Music]
i have with me
david pakman he is a progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is a beta
the baby david pacman
he
david is he is a pain
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot of people agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and then controlled by the darkness of
david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
david patman
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate that i'm coming all right
thanks for coming goodbye
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
all right everybody what an incredible
day we are here for the first
address from president-elect joseph
r biden jr as well as vice
president-elect
kamala harris and it is going to be
quite an evening and there is so much to
discuss i started
i was going to start five minutes before
the start of the event but i have so
much stuff that people have sent me and
things i want to show you and things to
go over
i had actually promoted that i was going
to be playing in a
charity among us event
tonight raising money for uh children's
hospitals
and because of this i am not doing that
right now
but at the end of the stream i'll tell
you more about that and we might raid
some of the other people like former
producer lewis motomedy people who
remember louis he is actually in the
middle of this right now
over as big lou 49 and
my thought is at a certain point we
might even raid him
excuse me or i might uh communicate with
him on discord or
let's just see what's going on
okay nothing all right very good so
anyway we will uh oh i see the whole
thing was muted let's see
nice work all right mr pacman okay oh
someone just mentioned my name
whoever did that oh i turned into a race
car that's weird i tuned in and somebody
said my name
but in any case we're gonna get to that
later right now we are preparing for
again an incredible day a day that
um donald j trump hoped would never even
come
and so we've got this going on a
producer speaking of producers
producer pat has 30 minutes of phony
phone calls
to the trump voter fraud line where he's
been calling and reporting
you know all sorts of crazy things and i
thought maybe i would call the voter
fraud line later but my idea
would be that i'm reporting like the
trump voter fraud line i'm reporting
voter fraud in favor of trump i thought
might be a funny thing
but we'll see that'll be like if the
stream goes really well we'll look at
doing that
um but there is just so much else to
discuss
now i i do want to say a couple of
things
many of you as you know well maybe not
as you know
there are many people in my audience who
did not support joe biden
in the primary there are people in the
audience
who ultimately did vote for joe biden
and then some people who didn't and you
know all sorts of different things
i think at this point it's really
important that we have a sort of
well-dialed in understanding of what was
accomplished and what was not
um this was the largest margin of
victory
from the standpoint of the popular vote
that we've ever had and it's still
building for joe biden
removing any incumbent president is very
difficult
bill clinton did it in 1992 so even
though there's a very good chance that
the final electoral
uh numbers are going to be um
exactly the same as as donald trump's in
2016 or whatever
removing an incumbent president is very
difficult when we talk about the power
of incumbency
trump gets to fly around doing rallies
in air force one right
biden doesn't have air force one trump's
the one who can use
even though he shouldn't the white house
for events
joe biden cannot and it's really just
important to understand
how difficult it is to remove an
incumbent president even if this had
been a 270 to 268 win
and we're going way beyond that it is a
major accomplishment
removing donald trump in order to
actually have someone start taking
coronavirus seriously i mean i just want
to remind you guys
today um 119
000 cases and a thousand deaths
yesterday a record hundred and thirty
two thousand cases
and nearly twelve hundred and fifty
deaths we need someone who right away
is going to start talking to governors
what is going on with masks what is
going on with schools we need somebody
who is going to take
actual doctors and say these are the
people that we need here
okay the importance of removing trump
cannot be
uh overstated we also want to recognize
that there's going to be a senate runoff
and the possibility of jon ossoff taking
a senate seat which right now we're just
enjoying what's going on and we're going
to hear from the president-elect
monday you can bet your ass that we're
starting with that georgia race
hugely hugely important um and
this is going to be uh this is not the
time to tune out
is the point uh because there is a lot
of work to do there's there's actually
two yes as people are pointing out
on on twitch chat there is also um
there's there's actually two runoffs
happening in georgia i think the assaf
one is the more likely one that could be
won
but i understand there are two senate
races there's a lot that needs to be
done here so this is not the time to
tune out
uh of politics is the point that i'm
trying to make now many of you were
waiting on the edges of your respective
seats
for the call today if you followed me on
instagram
you would have had your anxiety allayed
very early
because on my instagram today i posted
that i had an exclusive meeting with
oliver the boston pomeranian
he looked closely at the pennsylvania
data
and oliver has never missed a call uh
he actually was very comfortable with
with calling it for biden relatively
early and he was completely right
absolutely and completely right so if
you're not following me on instagram
why the hell not um but yes very very
strong call from oliver the boston
pomeranian not my dog it's my friend's
dog and he's just
he's really he's a savant it's not the
smartest dog
you know but when it comes to analyzing
election data he's just
really really good um and one of my
favorite
videos also on instagram from this week
is this one take a listen to this
[Applause]
knockout says knockout follows him and
luna says again
emblematic of this race there's arizona
handing off to wisconsin
looping pass to michigan set it up for
nevada and just
brutal and the entire sane world
absolutely losing their minds
do not scratch your eyes you are really
seeing the most extraordinary
okay anyway so that's that's on my
instagram and i i do hope that you are
uh that you're following me there very
very important and exciting stuff
okay um we are taking a fresh start we
really need a fresh start you know the
the
the great thing about now well actually
i'm gonna go i was gonna say the great
thing about a presidential election is
there's a clean break
january 20th is a clean break trump out
biden in
the problem is that there's no
indication donald trump is actually
going to
concede which is just a formality it's
not even clear donald trump is going to
accept that he is lost it's not even
clear donald trump
will be at the inauguration but to some
extent we're getting a fresh start and a
clean break and
in order to celebrate that we have a
brand new coupon code
fresh start all one word all lower case
and
you can use that code at joinpackman.com
any membership
this is actually there's actually police
about to break down the door and say
this deal is too good
the coupon code fresh start saves you 70
percent
at joinpakman.com which is crazy
it's like why am i even doing that but
but we are doing it
and i want to say thanks to the eight
people who have signed up so far
on my website very much appreciate it
we're also counting twitch subs because
it's an incredible day
uh 2235 puts this as plus
8 there which is 16. i'll say more about
that later
okay i'll say more about that later um
there is actually coupon fraud actually
it's actually it's fraud and
fraud it's both that's going on okay i
don't know how many of you know this
earlier today donald trump announced
that there was going to be as the race
was being called for joe biden
donald trump announced that there would
be a
um an event a press conference at the
four
seasons in philadelphia and a lot of
people thought oh that must be the four
seasons hotel
no no it was at a landscaping company
reportedly located between a crematorium
and a sex shop and rudy giuliani showed
up there
i haven't i've deliberately avoided
listen listening to anything about it
um i want to take a listen to what rudy
said let's listen because they don't
decide the election
the call for joe biden isn't is it
what was it called by all the oh my
goodness
all the networks wow
all the networks we have to forget about
the law
reportedly this was not a medical
incident this was i guess rudy met to
say this stuff
judges don't count all the networks all
the networks
all the networks thought biden was going
to win by 10
gee what happened come on don't be don't
be ridiculous networks don't get to
decide
by the way i this this is not like this
this is really so rudy giuliani
completely melting down
at a um landscaping uh facility
between a sex shop and a crematorium um
you know i i don't know who you guys
were watching or listening to before the
election and
maybe you were looking at a lot of
different people by the way thanks to
david chadman for an extraordinarily
powerful
50 donations of subscriptions on on
twitch that is wild that's extremely
powerful
thanks david chadman um
i had been saying from the very
beginning and i hope you guys remember
this
that when we see a poll that says biden
up 8 10 or 12
i have no expectation whatsoever that
biden is going to win by that much
and i made it clear that we should
expect a win
somewhere between um you know three and
six points
that that it is not going to be as big
of a win as those polls were predicting
so anyway it you know who cares what
rudy giuliani says at this point
it's i i actually tweeted i've been
tweeting pretty strongly today actually
and i tweeted not long ago
the world is improved by saying goodbye
officially to the likes of trump don jr
melania bill barr by the way no one's
seen bill barr
since the super spreader event at the
white house nobody is we don't even know
if he's alive
ivanka jared kushner kaylee mcgarnanny
jason miller
rudy giuliani betsy devos mike pompeo
and many others but rest assured they'll
continue to plague us in unofficial
ways these may all end up being fox news
contributors
um it it's uh so but but yes we are all
much better off by getting rid of these
people so let's see we already did this
what else did i have for you guys oh
we got a very strong endorsement today
tom arnold of you know uh
tom and roseanne you know you guys know
who i'm talking about tom arnold
tom arnold tweeted a really strong
endorsement of the david pakman show
today i've enjoyed this man's excellent
work
well he should talk to jesse lee about
that because jesse lee peterson doesn't
accept that i'm a man but
i've enjoyed this man's excellent work
check him out
so really really strong endorsement from
tom arnold of true lies fame and then
uh i did want to just briefly show you
that donald trump
his entire twitter feed is just riddled
with flags
about how his tweets are misleading his
tweets
are you know his claims are disputed
it's absolutely and completely crazy i
want to say thanks to shade
lang shade lang has just gifted 100
subscriptions
and has blown david chadman out of the
water
really really crazy there seems to be uh
people are going
people are out of control um this is
like indistinguishable from a satire
account or like the trump trolls i have
it's just
unbelievable all caps the observers were
not allowed into the counting rooms now
a lot of the debate that's happening is
as to
whether the observers should have been
allowed in
the observers were allowed in if you
actually talk to people in michigan
pennsylvania wherever trump is suing
there were republican and democratic
observers in every room
it's it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
what is going on
and um it's going to be you know one one
of the things i'm curious
actually to hear from you guys about
this one of the things that's been
notable
over the last 24 hours you know and even
longer well depending on how long
you you feel that this has been over
it's been amazing
how the whole atmosphere
has just changed where you know i think
96 that well you know call it a week ago
a week ago
when i see this stuff my blood pressure
would go up
oh my god he's doing it again this is
the president this is absolutely insane
um now when i see this it's like this
these are the these are the dying gasps
these are the death throes so to speak
of a guy who you know never should have
even been president to begin with
i actually let me read a text message
from
uh hold on a second my manager sent me a
message
he said the energy in the
air already feels different which i
think is just exactly the way to say it
and
we're not overstate we know we may not
have the senate
we know that republican obstruction is
going to become
you know a cartoonish farce we we
understand that stuff
uh but the door has been opened people
as they're as they're pointing out
cnn is just now saying this guy's a liar
and unfortunately
this is the stuff that should have been
going on all along that's that's the
unfortunate reality but at least it's
happening at least it's happening
um let's see here
avanian with a 600 swedish kroner super
chat says
trump will lose his public person
protection on twitter
when biden is installed we call it
inaugurated installed sounds a little
dystopian
on january 20th how long until he is
banned yeah i think um
i think that there's a good chance trump
trump is at risk of getting banned from
twitter once he doesn't have that public
person protection i think that's
absolutely true
joe says what crime are you breaking
with the coupon code well
much like trump would say you know what
it is the fake news media won't write
about it
but you all know what it is they spied
on my coupon codes
it it's the greatest political crime in
american history that's ever
ever ever been committed
oh casper stigard checking in from my
hometown
buenos aires with the question have us
windows started shrinking already
yeah i had a bunch of tweets about that
i was just i was having a grand old time
on twitter earlier
um what did i tweet hold on
uh when biden is sworn in do we have to
flush toilets 10 to 15 times like trump
says or is that going to be optional
does anyone know what day we can
officially expect thanksgiving to be
cancelled
indoor heating to be eliminated and all
guns to be confiscated
and then i think i had one more yeah
does the communism start immediately or
not until the inauguration
all all very good questions by the way
if you guys want to understand
why this is not the time where we can
tune out
there is no greater example
than the people who whose radicalization
has exploded listen to this email i got
today from edward
you are an ignorant sucker even jay
baker i assume they mean jim baker
has more sense under biden you baby
killers
you know using some other words
whoremongers racist bigots sodomizers
adulterers will fall by the hands of god
etc so i'm interested in what's etc
uh you are not going to keep killing
babies and live earthquake came
under obama's watch and will come again
under biden
all those stupid voters will pay obama
left giving billions
it's like hard to even parse it to iran
and i hope trump does worse to put you
heathens under his thumb
i will be moving out of the stupid
country the funny thing is
where where do you go like if you are
if you are so conservative that you have
to leave because biden's president where
the hell do you even
go where will even allow you first of
all but where do you even go it's it's
bizarre
you will be taken over by iran russia
china north korea because they will not
respect a woman child molester and a
dope-smoking thing named kami
when his brain is gone she will be in
charge and you heathens will really go
down no jobs means crooks will break
into your expensive homes
and molest your nasty women peace be
still so anyway
the point is this is not where we you
know when barack obama became president
the vigilance had to go up and we
actually have to get stuff done now
we actually have to get stuff done and
that's something that we all have to
have to remember um
people asking what's going on so
president-elect joseph r biden jr will
be
addressing the country in about 15
minutes
now i had some people emailing me saying
uh
you know david it's he's not
president-elect until december 14th
guys that's the case every year you're
saying that because
you believe trump's fraud claims the
term president-elect
is is used i understand what you're
saying the electors haven't certified
we're using the term president-elect
it's been called
trump has no sense you know sensical
uh sensible maybe better said path at
this point in time
okay let me update my subscriber numbers
we are now up to 48 website members
which is an additional 40
putting us at 56. we have a goal of 290
because that's the number of electoral
votes
that as of right now joe biden has if we
take a look at the
really really strong numbers nevada has
been called pennsylvania has been called
joe biden could get to 306 with georgia
and the popular vote lead has now gotten
to 4.4 million
uh record and also a 2.9
percentage point lead from the
standpoint of the popular vote
that's where we got our goal of 290.
we're also counting twitch subs
we are at 23.88 which is an additional
153
wait 153 plus 56 that's exactly that's
20209 okay
very good um
okay i have some other thing let's just
let me just go through what else i have
for you guys because i've so much
um oh okay we played this
on stream yesterday this is donald
trump's
spiritual advisor paula white and this
went instaviral okay and i asked for
memes and remixes so take a look at this
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike until you have
victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be that we would strike
the ground for you will give us victory
god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain okay
you guys came through in just 24 hours i
received
so many remixes and different things one
idea i had
was to that somebody should place me in
the background
and that's exactly what was done i
apologize that the quality on this one
isn't perfect but you've got to see this
this is just great stuff
keep an eye out for me in the background
okay strike and strike and strike and
strike
oh and also a nice touch on this one is
that you hear
trump saying plasma in the background if
you listen closely it's like
strike and perfect until you have
victory for every enemy that is aligned
against you
let there be that we would strike the
ground for you will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rage i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of shouting and singing i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of the button i hear a
sound a victory and here i come ready
here we go
[Music]
i hear a sound of victory there i am
[Music]
i think i come back a few times i hear
victory victory victory victory in the
quarters of heaven
victory victory am i coming back with my
papers
[Music]
there i am again
okay anyway so that one was really well
done and then i have some others as well
this
let me just make sure we're not missing
anything i still okay we still have a
little while until joe biden speaks
um okay jethro bradley has done some
fantastic
remixes for us and he sent me one
yesterday hot off the presses called
paula white is winning
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
[Music]
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i
[Music]
this is grammy material guys i'm not
gonna lie
[Music]
that's so good that's just it's just
it's
it really is unbelievable and then i got
um from dj physic this is from dj physic
this is another
this is another david pakman show
exclusive in the name of jesus
and secrecies and demonic plans and
networks we break it up and we command
that to be exposed right now in the name
of jesus
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike in the name of
jesus
strike and strike until you have a
different feel for every enemy that is
aligned against you
let there be that we would strike the
ground for you will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of shouting and singing i
hear a sound of victory
okay and then our good friend joseph
woodward he put one together
joseph woodward by the way is the um
composer
of such david pakman show classics as
david pakman is a beta male
[Music]
i have with me david pakman okay also
the author of plasma
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
giant virus that will save countless
lives
okay so anyway joe woodward put this
together very very strongly and quickly
this is called angels are being
dispatched right now
it would because it would be of an
antichrist spirit we break it right now
right name of jesus christ we break it
right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here
in the name
[Music]
[Music]
can you imagine i mean it's what what
you people have been able to do
is really unbelievable in in 24 hours
we have a video remix and three song
remixes and i
i still think one of the great moments
of this one uh
is right about here
i
[Music]
that's just genius and if you haven't
heard um jethro bradley also did
song for kamala
[Music]
jones is his running mate the most
liberal senator in america
kamala
senator
[Music]
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you for
coming for you
if you are under the age anyway really
really strong song and then also just
i'm catching people up there's so many
people here who haven't ever heard this
stuff
also from jethro bradley um this is
called suppression balls they want to
vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls you can't hold them
i'm soaking wet already
suppression falls yesterday we had three
big ones really big
suppression i'm soaking poles
already they put numbers you know
they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly
so you say to your wife or you say to
your husband darling let's go out to
dinner and then we'll come back we love
our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leading
well i'm soaking wet already
what does he say i'm soaking wet alright
that must have been from one of the
events where it was raining and trump
complained that it rained
can you guys imagine never having to
watch a trump rally again it's really
crazy but
th this is just it's cr it's crazy the
level of creativity
and uh ingenuity from people in the
audience really really really
unbelievable so i appreciate everybody
who
sent stuff in okay we are now just six
minutes
from the first national address we're
first expecting to speak
from vice president-elect elect kamala
harris
she of course will be the first woman to
ever be president or vice president and
happens to be a woman of color
uh her husband um will be the
i believe fact check me if you guys can
um her husband will be the first jewish
uh first uh a spouse of presidential or
vice
presidential spouse first second
gentleman i guess is what we're calling
it
um just very very interesting uh what
what we have
uh coming up here so we'll hear from
kamala harris
then we're going to hear from um
the actual president-elect joseph r
biden jr
so a lot of very important things and
then if you're just joining us i i
want to just remind you guys one more
time
that uh oh wait a second oh no i don't
have it anymore okay no i had an image i
was gonna put up but i don't have it
which is fine we have plenty plenty of
other things to do
okay um let me say thank you
to the additional 20 folks who just
signed up
on my website putting us at 229
once we add in twitch which is at 23.90
we go to 231. yeah so we we already
talked about
the how monday's gonna be a big show
because i'm gonna lay out the next two
months six months and 12 months
um in in some ways and one of the
important things is that
whether or not democrats get the senate
we're getting a fresh start here
and that's why we have this coupon code
fresh start i would really i
invite you i'm inviting you right now
this is a formal invitation
get a membership on my website
joinpakman.com these are really cheap
when we build our own revenue we become
sort of like immune
almost like a bubble around us from when
youtube might cut revenue or facebook or
things can happen on twitch or whatever
so if you've appreciated the coverage if
you've got you know a dollar eighty a
month is all we're talking about with
that coupon code fresh start
head on over to joinpakman.com sign up
you will move this bar it will fill up
and we we are now getting into the
difficult time you know
uh when when donald trump when we
expected hillary clinton to win in 2016
i had no um misperception
that the next four years were going to
be sitting back it was going to be
if hillary had won a president to my
right
who we would have had to really push to
get things done instead we got trump
okay and we've we've had to play defense
um for the last four years all that's
happened is we're getting the ball back
one of the balls we don't know exactly
what's going to happen in the senate
this is now the time where we have to
say hey joe biden you had these 50
campaign promises
we expect that stuff to happen um we
need to do
we need to do our work in the house uh
so so this is really the time
to start and i hope that we're gonna
have you guys with us
uh and this is all to say we have a
disgusting
coupon code that saves you 70 it's
called
fresh start and you can use it on
literally any membership you want on my
website joinpakman.com
could be monthly year with just whatever
you want we're not means testing it
it's just it's a disgusting disgusting
coupon code
people are talking me out of the coupon
code i actually may uh
i actually maybe talked out of it before
you know um okay
what else do we want to get to
oh uh yeah i've been thinking about
calling the trump
um voter suppression law or the voter
fraud line
let me see i guess eric trump's been
tweeting out the line the phone line let
me see if i can find it i'll try calling
it
um what is the number
he's been eric trump all day has been
saying if you're aware of any fraud
please call this number but now i can't
find the number unfortunately
does anybody know what number that is
oh man
i eight six seven five three oh nine
yeah that sounds right
that seems like it could be maybe
they've taken it down
maybe yeah i maybe i can't do it um
i was looking forward to doing that but
hold on did somebody text me the number
no
is this for real eight hundred eight
nine five four one five two i wanna like
actually
see it somewhere myself let me see trump
voter fraud
number trump's election fraud claims
make no headway
damn i'm not i'm just not sure hassan
gave out the number
yes so many people are like putting up
different numbers can someone tell me
where to find it
because if someone tells me where to
find it it's on eric's twitter people
are saying
yeah i'm just not seeing it
um the tweet is still
up let's see fraud
yeah i'm just not finding it
it's a picture on his twitter okay so if
i look at media
oh oh oh i think i found it okay let's
look at this
let's see report okay oh there it is
okay i'm gonna try it
let me just um we're gonna i'm gonna try
to call
the voter fraud line and see what's
going on
hold on a second now people are telling
me my website is down
website seems fine there's 400 people on
the website right now
but it seems fine oh it's getting a
little sluggish
yeah i apologize about that there's a
lot of people trying to sign up right
now
um unfortunately there's not too too
much i can do about that um it should it
should fix itself okay let's see
calls 800
see if we can do this new call dial pad
800-895-4152
let's just see what happens
all of our agents are busy helping other
customers customers
please record your message when you
finish all right
well that's not gonna work they must be
getting trolled
pretty aggressively right now the
website is working it's just slow guys
it's just so there's 500 people on the
website right now
um but it is it is it is working
um my idea so i actually i don't
because the voter fraud narrative is so
bogus about
fraud in favor of biden my
idea for calling the voter fraud line
was going to be
to say i'm reporting i i saw someone
with a wheelbarrow wearing a trump hat
and a wheelbarrow full of trump ballots
and i'm reporting trump voter fraud
and just see kind of how they respond
that was my idea
i'm not that clever with that stuff but
um
yeah i guess i guess we're not going to
be able to do it
then the numbers getting overwhelmed by
false reports
um okay let's see here wow almost 600
people on my website that's insane
we don't get that kind of traffic
typically
it's insane yeah rudy giuliani
reportedly is running the call center
you guys want to just see one more look
is there audio by the way what's going
on here
oh okay um this is
hold on where's the rudy i wanna if
you're just joining us i wanna show you
this
rudy four seasons check this out this
was rudy earlier today
at a location um between
a a porn store and a crematorium at a
landscaping shop this is this was what
he
but this is not the one i wanted hold on
there's a the video we played earlier is
really good
where is it uh yeah here it is check
this out
the poll
because they don't decide the election
the call for joe biden isn't
is it what was it called by
all the oh my goodness all the networks
wow all the networks
we have to forget about the law judges
don't count
i think that this is an important time
to mention that their their
their new idea now is that they're
trying to push the idea
that um something
there something bad has happened because
the judges haven't yet weighed in
like this is an election there's no rule
that says until judges weigh in on the
election the election isn't valid
it's ridiculous it's just even this
entire concept of legal votes versus
not legal votes um is is a complete
fiasco it's really really poor rudy
right
uh okay i'm being given a second number
let me see i'm being given another
number
oh i've got a second number that may be
one where we can actually report
i've got a second number where i might
be able to port report voter fraud on
the behalf of donald trump we're going
to check it out in a moment
but right now we are standing by now for
joseph r biden jr
he will be briefing us on the path
forward
as a president-elect for the first time
let me try one more call here
call number one
thank you for calling the trump national
war room
all of our agents are busy helping other
callers
at the tone please record your message
when you've finished recording
you may hang on yeah it's all shut down
guys i mean it's
people are just destroying these plays
these these numbers are not able to keep
up it's out it's completely out of
control
um okay uh abc news is now live waiting
for uh the president-elect
uh we are now inside the room live
waiting for the president-elect
and a lot is happening here this is
going to be
this is going to be very very
interesting this is going to be really
really interesting
a few super chats let me get to some
super chats i apologize that i've not
gotten to them
michael says trump is going out like
lotso went out at the end of toy story
three i didn't see that one
david belski says no one likes us no one
likes us no one likes us we don't care
we're from philly trump don't like us we
don't care
bola says is it safe to drop the panic i
know we have to stay on biden to do
right by us but
he's got no legal way to stop biden at
this point thanks
yeah there's no legal way that that that
makes sense you know
there are these different ideas that are
thrown around
very very hypothetical very very
um how would i say it far-fetched i
think is
is what i would say and amber gifford
says david do you think biden can
institute a national mass mandate and do
you think he will replace the surgeon
general or is that even a necessity
possible surgeon general i don't know
the president cannot put in a mass
mandate the president
can can do two things the president can
talk to governors like adults
and say listen let's do this
let's come together do a mass mandate he
can talk to governors and the governors
could do it
because that is something that's
regulated by the states if the federal
government wants to do a mass mandate
again this is
i'm not a lawyer this is the best
assessment i've gotten from lawyers
you could regulate through the commerce
uh commerce um regulation
powers of congress you could pass a bill
house senate signed by the president but
the president cannot unilaterally
issue a mass mandate to the best of my
knowledge
and um that is that is per lawyer so i'm
sticking with that
oliver says musical dr woodward please
incorporate
biden's speech into a new song title it
trump flags at half-mast there's an idea
for joe woodward
that's an idea cain not
kanye says now would be a good time for
the 25th amendment stop the damage
james says happy vt day and ralph says
jimmy from philly was apparently not
able to get out the vote there
yeah speaking of which just because we
have a little time
let me do a check of the voicemails to
see if some of the furious trumpists
have been calling in
um oh yeah yeah yeah listen to
okay um should i play this
this is one of the most vile callers we
have take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
um this may not be suitable for children
and in all likelihood it's not suitable
for
for children let's take a listen a
little prickles
now that your uh your hero is there are
you going to sit there in your little
kimono
and wear your little hat and eat rice
because you know
it's going to be called no free speech
red chinese communist speech
and it's like this is just so stupid
it's hard to even take it seriously
when you but you can't have pork because
you might offend the ayatollahs
no i i don't eat pork because i don't
eat pork it's not because
muslims wouldn't like it after all
they're gonna love this too
they're gonna make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
it's weird like trump got
out of the iran nuclear deal which would
free up iran to develop nukes it's a
can you understand how backwards it is
to say right
when obama got iran into the nuclear
deal
they were gonna make bombs while in the
deal
even though they abided by the deal
trump gets out of the deal
iran now has no reason not to start
redeveloping those nukes and the guy
says
if we get back into a deal iran is going
to i mean it's incoherent as i'm sure
you guys can tell
um and let's see
who uh oh i think this guy called in a
second time let's take a listen
hey danielle prickles
uh you ain't gonna be happy very long
because you know
we're gonna obstruct and we're gonna do
the same thing
to you demo rats and progressives as you
did to us
we're gonna do amy comey barrett's and
uh
uh kavanaugh's and whatever
whatever ain't gonna get any of his
choices put through
we're gonna freeze him out you bunch of
lion cheating son of a [ __ ] and
uh one good thing with biden
i heard that he already called corn
popped and his crew
his posse to be his security so we won't
have to pay
this is highly triggered i mean as you
guys can tell this is an extremely
triggered individual taxpayers won't
have to keep paying
uh for security guards because corn pops
gonna protect them
you guys are a bunch of lion cheating
bastards if you didn't cheat you
wouldn't win
you know it's so weird how like
biden just got more votes in enough
states to win
it you could you really couldn't have a
simpler election it's like wait a second
okay
who got more votes in pennsylvania biden
got more votes oh he won pennsylvania
and they're making it like this is you
know you need a um
uh a phd in uh advanced math you know
like to figure this thing out biden just
got more votes in enough states you do
flap your arms around and lay an egg lay
a big pile of [ __ ] in your pants
i bet you peed your pants when you heard
they uh
said that he supposedly won but he
didn't i guarantee you he's gonna end up
losing and trump's gonna stay in there
you're an [ __ ]
i'd like to stick that microphone right
up your ass but there's so much [ __ ]
between your
legs and your pants
you could flap around like a freaking
chicken you're a real queer
remember look out for corn pop and we're
gonna obstruct you
and we're gonna make it so difficult
that your his nominees
are gonna give up so let's see how uh
well he does a bunch of hawaiian
shits anyway so this is a little peek
behind the curtain
at what's going on um let me see if
anybody else called in like troy york
yeah okay so here's another guy this is
troy york he's seen
looking at the transcript he looks
pretty triggered yes david pakman the
integrity
of our electoral system has been
undermined
by the democrat party
they have completed complete and massive
voter fraud
and voter suppression
[Music]
uh they have used the mainstream media
to vote or suppress
for all the lies of your guests
uh greg palace
being the top one greg palace hasn't
been on the show for six or seven years
i don't know what he's talking about
he's made a career from his lives of
voter suppression yet african-americans
actual
voter suppression and manipulation
by the media you're calling or is he
talking about voter frogs is he claiming
frogs voted it's a weird pronunciation
man racist
and all that all your life from the
media and including
yourself in essence works
as vulgar suppression in essence
do you entrain people with your racist
inflammatory
rhetoric against trump i'm racist
against trump what's trump's race that
i've been racist against
that's weird to basically
volunteer this guy's calling in about
voter frogs
oh someone's calling right now calling
in about voter frogs
integrity tegrity this is weird
all right so anyway there's that and
then let me see if jimmy from philly
called in
oh we have voicemails from jimmy from
philly
you guys want to see the evolution of
this so
here's jimmy from philly on wednesday i
haven't pre
this is going to be a real treat let's
see what his
uh um what his uh mood was
as we wait for joe biden this is jimmy
from philly on wednesday let's take a
listen to that
jimmy from philly wiped hasn't killed it
no that trump's gonna win anyway
despite all this [ __ ] and even if
they call for him
he's gonna he's gonna learn in court
david the corruption is so massive
it's hard to imagine
you [ __ ] idiot smith it's too much
man
really it's quite entertaining david
keep
keep putting up some gasoline videos
because it's
entertaining david i i mean this all
right so that was jimmy from philly
wednesday
jimmy from philly called back again
yesterday let's see if his mood
changed at all david jimmy from philly
i'm reading your articles that trump
claims without evidence david every
[ __ ] thing that comes out of your
mouth is without evidence
there are scores of videos all over the
internet
poll workers changing ballots balances
all kind of a regular release whoa hold
on i got to listen to that again
how was that right was that
irregularities there let me listen to
that again
poll workers changing balance
there's all kind of irregularities
i can't even i don't even think i'm able
to pronounce that sound
ironies i don't even know what letter
that is i think that's a new letter
that's a 27th letter
david they can call biden the winner
all the [ __ ] day one right this shit's
gonna get tattled in court
believe me trump ain't going nowhere
so anyway that so all of our favorite
trumpet viewers are checking in really
really strongly just to give you guys a
sense of uh
what's going on behind the scenes man
that is exhausting
that is exhausting somebody's asking me
to use the pbs
feed okay i guess people would write do
you get do you guys want to see until
the speech starts
this the stage or do you want to see
the party let me know which one you guys
prefer
people prefer the party
most people seem to prefer the party
okay that's fair that's fair
okay let me get an updated count we are
up to 209
uh website members which puts us at
59 141
plus 231 would be
372 that's a strong number
and then we're counting twitch
um oh the twitch number went down
some people's monthly subs must be
expiring but let's see it looks like
we've got one two three four
five six seven eight okay
uh 23.83 that's an additional eight
which puts us at 380. that's great
uh yeah so our goal is going to be 538
just one for each uh each electoral vote
um okay we are very cl i mean i'm
guessing we're close
this is now um
what time is it 8 17 so we're now 20
minutes past
i guess uh oh now and producer pat is
texting me numbers as well
yeah these are so those are the two i
called pat yeah they're both off the
hook
we tried calling the trump voter fraud
number
and um oh hold on my attorney is sending
me a message you can't justify a full
mask
mandate under the interstate commerce
clause
maybe for interstate travel
transportation but not otherwise oh my
god
our attorney has spoken jesus i bet he's
billing me a half hour for that that is
really really crazy i think i just
i think i just got billed a half hour
because i read this text guys
but the david pakman show lawyer says no
go on
interstate i read something about that
from a lawyer that
to be perfectly frank mike i think is a
little bit more
in this field than you might be um no
i'm kidding
who could possibly be more in that field
but let me see if i can find it
uh mask mandate interstate
commerce clause jeez that was a 400 text
okay the civics project a federal mass
mandate would be difficult
um in theory the president acting
through hhs and cdc could issue a mask
order
however regulations under section 361
deal mostly with short-term quarantines
or even fumigation of goods
you know that's what biden should do he
should say if you don't mandate masks
we're going to come in and fumigate the
hell out of you fumigate for what
doesn't matter just
to avoid mass fumigations maybe people
governors would agree to just do mask
mandates courts may find
that a nationwide mass mandate would be
stretching this authority too far
people would also likely argue that the
mass order violates other constitutional
provisions or the rights of states under
the tenth amendment
some litigations have already raised
religion oh god religious freedom
objections can you imagine
um okay here's the relevant part
the commerce clause grants congress the
power to regulate activities that
substantially affect
interstate commerce thus congress could
probably require
any person engaged in commerce to wear a
mask
a broader requirement would likely face
more substantial legal opposition okay
so that's a little stronger actually
that's not just
if you are doing commerce across state
lines
it's if you're involved in commerce is
what it seems to say
congress also has the power of the purse
congress could allocate money to states
and localities to fight the
pandemic but require states taking money
implement a state level requirement okay
that's interesting
um there are limits on the ability of
congress to coerce states
tying money for a viral pandemic to
limit the spread seems likely to be
consistent with
previous judicial interpretation the
bigger issue might be politics
a bill would require significant
bipartisan agreement to happen
yeah so if democrats don't have the
senate that's certainly not happening
i'm actually thinking
the strongest move if we decide that we
want a mask mandate and again you know
the problem with the idea of a mask
mandate is if you're out hiking in the
woods
in you know eve wherever by yourself
we it would need to be done in a way
where nobody feels like it's
cartoonishly ridiculous
um but i think the best path would be
for biden to start talking to states
even while he's just president-elect
start talking to governors
and say listen work with me
let's do this let's actually have a
coordinated effort
uh we are expecting the vaccine not by
the way what happened to 100
million doses by october 31st we're
expecting the vaccine whatever is the
real date maybe we'll actually get the
real date soon
give give me two months of you know if
not a mandate
just really saying wear a mask all the
time
period because people do listen to a lot
of these covers i think just
just joke good old joe greasing the
wheels
may be the um the the only way to go
okay hold on i'm getting more texts
oh okay i'm only getting billed a
quarter hour for that
good very good it's like i'm gonna i
might need to hire another lawyer to
evaluate whether
these are valid whether i'm being
properly right by
speaking of which i tweeted about this
yesterday where was this
um caitlyn collins tweeted about it
and it's just so funny hold on
where is that video i need to find it it
was
last night i tweeted about it oh here it
is this is the best
caitlyn collins reported yesterday that
trump is wondering whether his lawyers
are really the right legal team
to essentially to steal the election on
these spurious grounds take a listen to
this
but the question that the president
himself seems to be raising tonight
is about the team that he's assembled to
fight for him in court
we've seen so far that's been rudy
giuliani the former florida florida
attorney general pam bondi
matt morgan who's a trump campaign
attorney and a few others but jake
we're being told tonight by sources that
the president is raising questions
about the effectiveness of that team and
asking people
trump is starting to wonder whether
rouley can rudy who
uh uh you know today did an event at
um a landscaping company between a porn
shop and a crematorium
trump may be questioning whether rudy
will really be able to get the election
back from going to be able to properly
fight for him and do a good enough job
basically suggesting he doesn't think
that they're up to the task and he's
even told one person he wants them to
find him better attorneys
to put on his team because he wants a
team of what he described to one person
understand how stupid this is this is
like if i if i hire a lawyer for
something
that's ridiculous like i fire a lawyer i
hire a lawyer to get me to mars
in the next three weeks and then i say
you know i'm i'm not sure that this
lawyer is up to the task of getting me
to mars in the next three weeks like
well no
it's an impossible task of course the
it's not the lawyer's fault
um it it's just unbelievable
we're um i guess almost a half hour late
here
maybe this is something that joe biden
is going to pick up on
from trump just being late to events
but we're first expecting to hear from
kamal harris
vice president-elect first woman
president or vp
in the united states woman of color she
will be ushering in
the first jewish second uh
second gentleman uh doug
uh what is doug's last name i just
blanked on doug's last name
ellsmore what's his last name i forget
now
emhoff yes exactly doug emhoff
no not doug stanhope uh doug emhoff
and then of course joe biden will be
taking office
as the oldest president ever to take
office
only the second catholic president to
take office the other being
of course john f kennedy
um and so a very very interesting uh
administration coming in there are
starting to be rumors about who might be
um on the docket so to speak
in terms of uh cabinet you know
i still think given another four years
jared kushner could solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict i think he
just ran out of time
so i think that that's something that
maybe joe biden should consider i think
kushner maybe is the right guy he just
didn't get enough time and he was so
busy
getting everybody ventilators and doing
masks and schwabs and everything i think
kushner was just
brought elsewhere i think we we
definitely want to have him back in no
but i read um pete but edge edge
maybe for va secretary which i think is
actually interesting because
the the the idea of having someone
of course pete budah judge being a
veteran but
having a certain political bent i i
actually think that that's interesting
i think that that would be very very
interesting and um
elizabeth warren's name not floated so
far i think warren would be interesting
for
treasury secretary quite frankly or
secretary of education
um bernie you know the thing about
bernie is is bernie more useful in the
senate
don't we need bernie's voice in the
senate i think that that's a real
question it's not clear to me that you
definitely want to take bernie out of
the senate
i would be interested in hearing from
you guys about that maybe if we open the
phone lines a little bit later
uh hud i don't know people are asking me
about secretary of housing and urban
development
um and and by the way elizabeth warren's
absence as people are pointing out
would also uh from the senate would also
potentially be
um something uh negative there andrew
yang i mean yeah listen andrew yang
um he could be secretary of commerce
andrew yang could be uh i think there
are potential
spots for somebody like andrew yang i
don't know
i don't know but we're there's going to
be time
there's going to be time people talking
about preet bharara for attorney general
um
[Music]
we are going to need to appoint a
secretary of the laptop from hell
so we can figure out what exactly
happened there
i still want to figure out um
i want to know more about the laptop
repair guy to be perfectly honest
because
this guy must be really good i mean to
have
to be a blo imagine being a blind laptop
repair guy
and people fly across the country to
have you repair their laptops
you must be able to do something with
these laptops that no one else has ever
been able to do
um i think that there's a lot a lot to
figure out there yeah the laptop from
hell
a uh a very very clever way to refer to
it
you i i have to say i am going to miss
some of the things that come out of
donald trump's mouth
but we will be all better off with them
gone like the laptop from hell is funny
um trump stories that start with sir
including ones where supposedly melania
came to him and said
sir they weren't talking about your
nobel peace prize on tv or whatever
sir is absolutely great uh trump talking
about convalescent plasma i mean we're
going to miss all this stuff all right
here is vice president-elect kamala
harris and she is going to make i
i imagine a very powerful statement here
and we will monitor donald trump's uh
twitter feed for despondency as this
continues
[Applause]
just the last 15 seconds i'm sure have
triggered so many people
um it's uh
this is this is going to be an
interesting interesting couple of years
for sure
let's listen
good evening good evening
good evening
good evening thank you thank you
good evening
so thank you good evening
[Applause]
so congressman
john lewis congressman john lewis oh
this is going to be triggering
his passing wrote democracy is not
a state it is an act
and what he meant was that america's
democracy is not guaranteed
it is only as strong as our willingness
to fight for it
to guard it and never take it for
granted
and protecting our democracy takes
struggle
it takes sacrifice but there is
joy in it and there is progress
because we the people have
the power to build a better future
[Music]
and when our very democracy was on the
ballot
in this election with the very soul
of america at stake and the world
watching you ushered in
a new day for america
[Applause]
to our campaign staff and volunteers
this extraordinary team thank you
for bringing more people than ever
before
into the democratic process
and from making this victory possible
to the poll workers and election
officials across
our country who have worked tirelessly
to make sure every vote is counted
clever to slip that in
owes you a debt of gratitude
[Applause]
you have protected the integrity of our
democracy
and to the american people who make up
our beautiful country thank you
for turning out in record numbers to
make
your voices heard
and i know times have been challenging
especially
the last several months the grief
sorrow and pain the worries
and the struggles but we have also
witnessed
your courage your resilience
and the generosity of your spirit
for four years you marched
and organized for equality and justice
for our lives and for our planet
and then you voted
and you delivered a clear message
you chose hope and
unity decency
science and yes truth
[Music]
you chose joe biden
as the next president of the united
states of america
wow
and joe is a healer a uniter
a tested and steady hand
a person whose own experience of loss
gives him a sense of purpose that will
help us
as a nation reclaim our own
sense of purpose and a man with a big
heart who loves with abandon
it's his love for jill who will be an
incredible first lady
she will be best we can be sure about
that it's his love
for hunter and ashley and his
grandchildren and the entire biden
family
[Applause]
and while i first knew joe as vice
president
i really got to know him as the father
who loved beau my dear friend
who we remember here today and
to my husband doug
[Music]
and our children cole and ella and my
sister maya
and our whole family i love you all more
than i can ever express
we are so grateful to joe and jill for
welcoming our family into theirs
on this incredible journey and to the
woman most responsible for
my presence here today my mother
shyamala gopalan harris
who is always in our hearts
when she came here from india at the age
of 19 she maybe
didn't quite imagine this moment but she
believed so deeply
in an america where a moment like this
is possible
and so i am thinking about her and about
the generations of women
black women
asian white latina
native american women
who throughout our nation's history
have paved the way for this moment
tonight
women who fought and sacrificed so much
for equality and liberty and justice
for all including the black women who
are often too
often overlooked but so often prove they
are the backbone
of our democracy
all the women who have worked to secure
and protect the right to vote for over a
century
100 years ago with the 19th amendment
55 years ago with the voting rights act
and now
in 2020 with a new generation of women
in our country who cast their ballots
and continued the fight for their
fundamental right to vote and be heard
tonight i reflect on their struggle
their determination and the strength of
their vision
to see what can be unburdened
by what has been and i stand on their
shoulders
and what a testament it is to joe's
character
that he had the audacity to break one of
the most substantial barriers that
exists in our country
and select a woman as his vice president
but while i may be the first woman in
this office
i will not be the last
because every little girl watching
tonight
sees that this is a country of
possibilities
and to the children of our country
regardless of your gender our country
has sent you a clear message
dream with ambition lead
with conviction and see yourselves in a
way that others may not
simply because they've never seen it
before
but know that we will applaud you every
step of the way
and to the american people no matter who
you voted for
i will strive to be a vice president
like joe was to president obama loyal
honest and prepared waking up
every day thinking of you and your
family
because now is when the real work begins
right the hard work
the necessary work the good work
the essential work to save lives and
beat this
epidemic to rebuild our economy
so it works for working people to root
out systemic racism in our justice
system and society
to combat the climate crisis to unite
our country and heal the soul of our
nation
and the road ahead will not be easy
but america is ready and so
are joe and i
we have elected a president who
represents
the best in us a leader
the world will respect and our children
will look up to a commander-in-chief who
will respect our troops
and keep our country safe and a
president
for all americans
and it is now my great honor
to introduce the president-elect
of the united states of america joe
biden
joe doing the jog is anybody else
finding it jarring that
the speech wasn't riddled with lies and
insulting other people it's actually
i'm feeling the absence of those
elements of a speech
um because it's it's kind of weird like
she didn't insult
anybody she didn't tell a hundred lies
or mispronounce 20
things while making completely and
obviously bogus claims it's strange
that point was actually a little
presidential history for you that
pretending to spot something in the cr
even if it just like a sign acting like
you saw someone bill clinton perfected
that thee
fellow americans
will joe deny science during this speech
delawareans
i see my buddy tom senator tom carper
down there and i think
i think senator coons is there and i
think the governor's around and
is that ruth ann and former governor
ruth ann minor
most importantly my sister's in law my
sister valerie
anyway
folks the people of this nation have
spoken
they've delivered us a clear victory
a convincing victory a victory
for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast
from presidential ticket
in the history of the nation 74 million
what i must admit is surprise me tonight
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
and i'm humbled by the trust and
confidence
you've placed in me i pledge to be a
president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states of blue
states only sees the united states
and work with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
and for that is what america
i believe is about it's about people
and that's what our administration will
be all about
i sought this office to restore the soul
america
to rebuild the backbone of this nation
the middle class
and to make america respected around the
world again
to unite us here at home
it's the honor of my lifetime that so
many millions of americans have voted
for that vision
and now the work of making that vision
is real
it's a task the task of our time
folks as i said many times before
i'm jill's husband
[Music]
and i would not be here without
her love and tireless support
of jill and my son hunter
and ashley my daughter and all our
grandchildren
and their spouses and all our family
they're my heart joe's a mom a military
mom an educator
and she has dedicated her life to
education but teaching isn't just what
she does
it's who she is for american educators
this is a great day for you all
[Music]
you're going to have one of your own in
the white house
and jill's going to make a great first
lady i'm so proud of her
but what about betsy devos i don't know
well i'll have the honor of serving with
a fantastic vice president
you just heard from kamala harris who
makes history as the first woman
first black woman the first woman from
south asia descent
the first daughter of an immigrant ever
elected in this country
don't tell me it's not possible in the
united states
it's long overdue and we're reminded
tonight
of those who fought so hard for so many
years
to make this happen but once again
america's bent the ark of the moral
universe more toward justice
kamala doug like it or not
your family you become an honorary part
and there's no way out
[Applause]
all those of you volunteered and worked
the polls
in the middle of pandemic local elected
officials
you deserve a special thanks from the
entire nation
and to my campaign team and all the
volunteers
and all who gave so much of themselves
to make this moment possible
i owe you i owe you i owe you everything
and all those who supported us i'm proud
of the campaign we built and ran
i'm proud of the coalition we put
together the broadest
and most diverse coalition in history
democrats
republicans independents progressives
moderates conservatives
young old urban suburban rural
gay straight transgender white latino
asian
native american
i mean especially those moments
and especially for those moments where
this campaign was at its lowest ebb
the african-american community stood up
again for a minute
you've always had my back and i'll have
yours
[Applause]
i said at the outset i wanted to
represent this campaign to represent and
look
like america we've done that now that's
what the administration will look like
and act like for all those of you
who voted for president trump i
understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
very untrump-like to put away the harsh
rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
they are not our enemies they are
americans
they are americans
the bible tells us to everything there
is a season
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow
and a time to heal this is the time to
heal in america
[Applause]
now this campaign is over
what is the will of the people what is
our mandate
i believe it's this americans have
called upon us
to marshal the forces of decency the
forces of fairness
to marshal the forces of science and the
forces of hope
and the great battles of our time the
battle to control the virus
the battle to build prosperity the
battle to secure
your family's health care the battle to
achieve racial justice
and root out systemic racism in this
country
and the battle to save our planet by
getting climate under control
the battle restore decency defend
democracy
and give everybody in this country a
fair shot that's all they're asking for
a fair shot folks
our work begins with getting covered
under control
we cannot repair the economy restore our
vitality
or relish life's most precious moments
hugging our grandchildren our children
our birthdays weddings
graduations all the moments that matter
most to us
until we get it under control on monday
i will name a group of leading
scientists and experts
as transition advisors to help
take the biden harris code plan and
convert it
into an action blueprint that will start
on january the 20th
yeah this is exactly what we talked
about yesterday he should start a
parallel coronavirus task force right
now sounds like he's going to do it
it'll be constructed out of compassion
empathy and concern
i will spare no effort none
or any commitment to turn around
this pandemic folks
i'm a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who didn't
vote for me
as those who did
let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
it's not some mysterious force beyond
our control
it's a decision a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate
then we can decide to cooperate
and i believe that this is part of the
mandate
given to us from the american people
they want us to cooperate
in their interest and that's the choice
i'll make
and i'll call on congress democrats
republicans alike
to make that choice with me the american
story
is about slow yet steadily widening the
opportunities in america
and make no mistake too many dreams have
been deferred for too long
we must make the promise of the country
real for everybody
no matter their race their ethnicity
their faith
their identity or their disability
folks america has always been shaped by
inflection points
by moments in time we've made hard
decisions about
who we are and what we want to be
lincoln in 1860 coming to save the union
fdr in 1932 promising a beleaguered
country
a new deal jfk
in 1960 pledging a new frontier
and 12 years ago when barack obama made
history he told us
yes we can
[Applause]
well folks we stand at an inflection
point
we have an opportunity to defeat despair
to build a nation of prosperity and
purpose
we can do it i know we can i've long
talked about the battle
for the soul of america we must restore
the soul of america our nation is shaped
by the constant battle between our
better angels
and our darkest impulses and what
presidents say
in this battle matters it's time
for our better angels to prevail tonight
the whole world is watching america
and i believe at our best america is a
beacon for the globe
we will not leave we will lead not only
by the example of our power
but by the power of our example
[Applause]
i've always believed many of you heard
me say it
i've always believed we can define
america in one word
possibilities that
in america everyone should be given an
opportunity to go as far as their dreams
and god giving ability will take them
you see
i believe in the possibilities of this
country
we're always looking ahead ahead to an
america that's freer and more just
head to an america that creates jobs
with dignity and respect
ahead of america that cures diseases
like cancers
and alzheimer's ahead to an america that
never
leaves anyone behind a head of america
that
never gives up never gives in
this is a great nation it's always been
a bad bet to bet against america
we're good people this is the united
states of america
and there's never been anything never
been anything we've been able not able
to do
when we've done it together folks
in the last days of the campaign i began
thinking
about a hymn that means a lot to me and
my family particularly my deceased son
beau
it captures the faith that sustains me
in which i believe sustains america and
a hope
and i hope it can provide some comfort
and solace the 230
million thousand americans who've lost a
loved one to this terrible virus this
year
my heart goes out to each and every one
of you hopefully this
him gives you solace as well and it goes
like this
and he will raise you up on eagle's
wings
bear you on the breath of dawn and make
you to sign like the sun
and hold you in the palm of his hand
and now together on eagle's wings we
embark on the work
that god and history have called upon us
to do
with full hearts and steady hands
with faith in america and in each other
with love of country
a thirst for justice let us be the
nation that we know we can be
a nation united a nation strengthened a
nation healed
the united states america and ladies and
gentlemen
there's never never been anything we've
tried we've not been able to do
so remember as my grandpop our
grandpappy's saying when i walked out of
his home
when i was a kid up in scranton he said
joey keep the faith
and our grandmother when she was alive
she'd yell no joey spread it
spread the faith god love you all may
god bless america
and may god protect our church thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
wow a very very different speech um
joe biden leaving the science denial
completely out of the speech
leaving the insults and the nicknames
completely out of the speech
leaving attacks out of the speech
and uh very very different than what
we've been used to that's for sure
um jarring almost seeing joe biden and
kamala harris
relate to their loved ones like normal
people something we've not seen
at all from donald trump uh it's not
even really clear he likes his wife
for kids or that they really like him
other than seeking their
his approval in some kind of uh strange
way
but very very different for sure than
what we have been
seeing for the last four years that's
for sure no mention of quack cures or
saying
he or others should or could inject
themselves with bleach
or take hydroxychloroquine or anything
like that
really just an injection of sanity um
and uh wow wow wow wow what a day
uh the work the work continues right and
i think it's important when when we
watch this to remember
uh you know it's not like now we get
everything we want and see
health care is done and the virus is
fixed it's just an inflection point i
think is the important way to say it
exactly the way that joe biden did i
think that that is the
key there is hunter biden uh clearly
he's still alive and we figured out
where he is and he's here he doesn't
have the laptop from hell with him or
anything like that
uh probably has a phone but no no laptop
at least that i can see
uh kamala harris's husband doug emhoff
um again just notable in its normality
guys that that's
i don't know how else to say it it's
just everybody's acting like normal
people
and it doesn't mean we agree with them
on all policy
um but it means that we at least can
have conversations that are
like normal people and that is a big big
change let's listen to a little more of
what's going on
all right getting a little risky as far
as copyright goes with the tom petty so
we
we know uh even posthumously tom petty
could be very very aggressive as far as
the as far as the copyright goes
donald trump um i believe not tweeting
during this let's just
check um if he did tweet it would
certainly be in all caps but
nope no tweets donald trump's last word
hours ago 71 million legal votes the
most
ever for a sitting president of course
75 million legal votes
the most ever for any candidate and
really you know the the kind of
stupidity of that is as the country's
population grows
um you would expect that the number of
votes any one can that it can can garner
would go up
what matters to me is turnout and um
uh of course the margin and the margin
is looking pretty pretty damn strong
right now and of course as
many people are pointing out the uh
the this concept of legal votes they are
votes
right there are votes i know i people
are noticing that ymca
is not playing um that is that is
that is welcome for me i'm told don jr
is tweeting let's just take a look at
that
donald trump jr
uh people where is donald trump jr here
he oh no hold on
donald trump jr here it is he is
reportedly tweeting no he's not tweet oh
wait you know 54 minutes ago
the media spent five years falsely
calling trump
a racist and misogynist and yet he
increased his support with women in
every minority group
oh my god
pack your bags this it's like who cares
how long are they going to do
they should they should all just stop
tweeting what is the point just the
level of being triggered at this point
is crazy
listen i want to hear from some of you
guys let's open up the phone lines on
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and um here hear from you
you go to davidpakman.com discord you
get into the waiting lobby
change your nickname to location colon
name location colon name and
if you are a trump supporter i would be
interested in knowing that
put at the beginning trump of your
location
if if anybody is is just lying about
that in order to get on
then we will stop going to all of those
people so please don't lie about it we
all lose
if you lie about it uh okay let's go
first to
jeff from atlanta jeff from atlanta oh
hold on a second
actually everything is going wrong here
let me first connect
uh jeff from atlanta are you on
yes i am can you hear me david yeah
what's going on
hey um great to hear from you i'm
actually glad that i
got to speak with you um i wanted to ask
if you think that there is going to be
any remnants of the trump administration
left
once uh biden takes over do you mean in
terms of people that will work for biden
or just if trumpism will be around
uh so trump actually like like like
trump
family oh my god no of course no they're
not even
they're not even officially there now i
mean that's the crazy thing that
no no ivanka's out they're all out my
friend
they should be out in the next week if i
were them i would just get rid of them
now
that is a very comforting thing to say
hey and uh i really appreciate you
taking my call and
love your rise to success and hope
that things go well for you this year
thanks very much that is it that's a
perfect phone call
if i've ever seen one that is a
beautiful phone call
let's go next to um
where do we want to go next there's just
so many people
um all right let's go to ronald reagan
just briefly um what what's going on
hey d man how you doing good how are you
uh pretty good i i want to get your uh
take on
something that's making me anxious okay
which is um
the the talk of uh unity and coming
together on the one hand
i intellectually i understand that he
kind of has to say that stuff
on the other hand i i worry that he
might be naive and he might be the kind
of guy
who's going to want to be cutting deals
you know cutting social security in
order to get
whatever joe biden is not going to cut
social security that
so let you're saying a lot of things
that are perfectly phrased
but joe biden is not cutting social
security put it out of your mind
that is not that's not happening where i
think the naivete
or naivete i've heard it pronounced both
ways i prefer naivete
where i think you're right is if joe
biden expects
to make deals with republicans in the
senate
get the hell out of here you know i mean
it's it's what what would have to be
given up in order to do that is
laughable and he should never do it
these are toxic terrible people
they said in 2016 you don't put somebody
in
during the in the supreme court in the
last year they put someone in
seven days before so forget that now if
joe biden
wants to you know nominally put a put
one republican
somewhere in a position you know get
some republican ambassadors and
maybe maybe an undersecretary somewhere
okay yeah i'm okay with that as long as
it doesn't disrupt
his actual policy but if he's expecting
to be making deals with republicans like
normal people i agree with you 100
percent it's ridiculous
reagan hello yeah oh you're there
i got it cut off all right thanks jay
all right thank you very much and you're
still your spanish is strong still right
i've heard
it's very strong um some some are saying
uh more and more people are talking
about it actually um
but uh yeah more and more people
do you there's one question when you rep
do you represent clients in spanish
uh well i mean i meet with them
in spanish and uh do a lot of
translating
my uh bachelor's is in spanish
interpretation and translations
is that right and then where is your
where's your jd from
uh university of oregon that's a strong
college actually that's a strong college
yeah so have me on your show some of
your spanish shows sometime we'll talk
immigration and uh
yeah you know all right counselor thank
you
all right all right very good there's a
ronald reagan
attorney at law not his real name
obviously
um but a good guy a good guy for sure
let's go next to hallie from texas texas
came so close hallie
hey yeah and i was really hoping that we
would pull it through this year but we
actually made a pretty good decent
representation
absolutely the big cities oh my god yeah
correct me if i'm wrong hallie but
houston austin and san antonio
and dallas all going blue right but is
fort worth sort of the pariah there
um yeah it's like the largest it's like
the densest city
um fort worth is like right outside of
dallas and they went red i believe
yeah it's kind of like a lot of the
older people
in that city live in fort worth and then
like kind of travel in it's like the
suburbs
got it well what can i do for you yeah
so i had one specific question with all
like the
and i'm holding up quotation marks here
but
the controversies as far as um voter
fraud
right the only thing that i was
specifically worried about was since we
do have
a pandemic that's going on right now um
what if someone were to mail in a vote
and then pass away
during that count
um i believe that in other words it was
a legal vote at the time that they cast
it but they died by november 3rd
yes to be perfectly frank i think those
votes probably count
and i think it's it's an insignificant
number
okay that was my only question curious
are you clicking a mouse or typing
something
i am typing i have to make a mechanical
keyboard oh okay and are you are you
like uh what are you i'm curious as
we're talking what are you typing like
what do you find it
what are you typing now i am playing a
video game because i'm a gamer
cool all right any particular game um
black desert online it's
a mmo mmo all right very good okay halle
from texas thank you you will be getting
a number of different
dating requests now from the people
watching on twitch uh but
that would be something you can deal
with later thank you i'm so excited
can't wait
thanks david gamers rise up thank you so
much okay
let's go next to what a night right
let's go next to um
maybe someone we've not spoken to before
how about carter from colorado
carter
carter you're on live oh carter bailed
okay i'm sorry
carter bailed um let's see instead then
wow there's people from a lot of
different countries
i don't know where it's most interesting
to go
let's try again i tried him the other
day
guido from argentina i would love to
have an argentinian on you're on the air
right now
bien
okay so this is a great question which
is um
am i worried that trumpism will continue
and the answer is
it's nothing i'm worried of course it
will continue
70 million people voted for trump
and so this is a mind virus and
um we we have to understand that it's
not
about um you know sure there are
ignorant trumpets but it's not really
about ignorance
and sure there are trumpists who just
don't care about other people but that
misunderstands it and
the democratic party needs to understand
biden almost didn't win completely
mishandled pandemic
insulting people global laughing stock
on and on and on and trump almost got
re-elected
and so trumpism is going to remain and
democrats had better figure out that if
you can't win easily in this situation
you're probably doing something a little
wrong
um
okay so my last question there was you
know milanesa
a traditional argentinian dish with
italian origin he prefers
the beef i prefer the chicken but that's
something for uh
that'll brought that that's a you know
that's a debate as old as time itself
for at least
you know 150 years we'll have to wait to
adjudicate that
let's go to kelly this should be
interesting kelly from helsinki
uh helsinki finland i presume
kelly from helsinki you're on
kelly from how are you doing oh it's a
oh it's a gentleman named kelly
yeah indeed how are you uh
doing well here in helsinki thank you so
much for taking my call
it's quite late there is it not yeah
it's like four
got it well i won't keep you up too long
then
oh i've been staying awake for days the
with this stuff
and it's been crazy but happy to see
biden win
absolutely yeah
did you have a question today or well um
i was just thinking that uh after trump
leaves office
that he would become a right-wing
conspiracy person
like uh bannon and limbaugh well he
doesn't really he's already won i mean
he doesn't have to leave in order to
make that happen
yeah indeed yeah yeah
so at any rate thanks so much for taking
my call but well before you go
um helsinki uh i i love helsinki
have you ever been to i believe it's a
place called
oh hold on a second it's a burger place
the owner was on some
cooking show it's called like uh
not tasty burger is it like yummy burger
or do you know what place i'm talking
about it's not too far from
well there's a burger oh no that's not
it's just a chain
no no not a chain no no no yeah i'm not
sure which one you're talking about is
it naughty burger is there a place
called naughty burger
oh well there is something uh gosh
it could be naughty burger or something
like that yeah
wow yeah okay well i've been there and
then the other thing i would say
is there is this central
sort of i guess it's a central market
um and it is near i think a train
station maybe
and there's all these stalls food stalls
what's it called yeah there's there's uh
there's
a that's a food a food chain there's a
whole food market
near the uh the sema we call them assam
as their stations here in helsinki
yes and so on so as an american living
here in finland
okay you just got cut off oh so you're
american you're not finn
hello okay he's gone very good i think
he's self-owned there that's weird
um i don't know what happened there that
was that was really strange
uh that's bizarre he's just
gone um okay all right well we're going
to move on i was going to i was going to
do a rant about smoked salmon but all
right let's go to a supposed trumpus
danny in the uk
danny you're in you're in the uk and
you're a trumpist
hi david yeah um so i was actually uh
born in the uk
but i moved to san bernardino county uh
i voted for trump in 2016. i voted for
trump this year
purely because i feel like
we don't have enough background
information
on the epstein thing and possibly joe
being involved i know i see a lot of
pictures of him
sniffing kids i don't know if those have
been edited hold on one second let me
just stop you right there
you know trump and epstein were friends
right did you know that
i do okay did you know trump and epstein
were both named as defendants
in a rape case by a 13 year old
i did okay and did you know that trump
has spent
spent time with epstein and has been on
his plane and like there's
there's no connection between biden and
epstein you know that right
uh no i actually i heard that uh yeah he
had a
well you you heard but you know about
trump's connection right
no but you just said you were aware of
the things i just mentioned you said yes
i know that was 30 seconds ago
and he's gone okay all right that was uh
jesus that is that is weaponized
if that's real that's extremely
weaponized let's go to paulina
from melbourne australia paulina you're
on the air
hi david can you hear me you're coming
in loud and clear
hi um i just want to say congratulations
on
your youtube channel and all the
viewership i've been watching the last
couple days
thank you with very little sleep but i'm
very happy
with the outcome and i'm so excited for
joe biden and kamala
do you believe that from the standpoint
of australia
will we be less of a laughing stock now
definitely a hundred percent that's good
100
um trump in the last four years
has literally been a joke yeah and um
yeah and for a lot of australians it was
just
embarrassing and out of curiosity is
there a rivalry between australians and
new zealanders or is it
relatively collegial no i think
um for both countries we're pretty much
friends
and comrades we just joke with each
other every once in a while
like we get competitive when it comes to
like certain sports
maybe um really but yeah no yeah
i think rugby um i'm not a sport type
but i think it's like just
sports and stuff like that but no we're
all good where is the coffee better
because new zealand i know
is very very pretentious about their
coffee
oh no melbourne coffee is better it is
oh wow okay so i think we've hit a nerve
we've hit a nerve
yeah i know melbourne coffee is really
good excellent all right
i hope to someday adjudicate it myself
definitely it should definitely calm
down but um i'll just say just as a
comment i think
with joe biden's speech um it was just
really nice
to hear something that's non
divisive yes and just a really normal
um uniting people right nothing about
you know um no contempt no hatred
he didn't insult anybody he didn't
accuse anyone of dementia without
evidence he didn't accuse anybody of
being unable to think without evidence
he didn't had do any of that yeah yeah
so that was really nice to hear now i do
think it's relevant to say let's just
mention
this is a complete this is the right
speech for today
eventually we're going to be judging
biden on what he gets done as it should
be
oh 100 absolutely paulina it sounds like
we're 100
uh um simpatico
awesome thanks so much okay thank you so
much there's paulina from melbourne
australia
uh people wanting to check in from all
over the world
let's go to um let's go to a trumpist
from
maryland trump is from maryland you're
on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can
all right just want to ask you one big
question here yep
um how's your channel gonna do since
trump's out
i think it'll do very well you think so
yeah i mean the channel's been growing
for 11 years so
and trump was in for three and a half of
them so i think i think it'll do well
but generally you would say the growth
was
exponentially bigger when trump was
around right
um well let's see there's a lot of
trumpists who struggle with exponential
growth and that concept what do you mean
by exponential
i mean generally greater than before
trump was even introduced to your
channel okay because that's very
different so so that's so you're just
saying was there greater growth the
answer is yes there was greater growth
yeah that's right yeah but not not
exponential
okay great greater but still you know
bigger than it was
before yeah so
how how's it gonna go from here on out
are you still gonna be uh
still because there's gonna be
like biden is is the positive side
supposedly right
so sorry what you're saying what you
said what by biden's the positive side
of what of the leftists right
so now there's no right supposedly like
all we have is the senate
and that's it no there's still 70
there's still 70 there's still 70
million trumpists
um it's unclear who's going to control
the senate yeah but what
i'm not i guess i'm not sure what i know
what you're asking
i'm just generally speaking that overall
i don't see your channel growing
since trump's out i'm wondering why you
would say that
given that it grew during george w bush
and barack obama and why would the
growth stop
now because it reached its peak right
trump's getting out of office now okay
and what pretty much uh what evidence do
you have for that
uh let's see in the past uh let's see
let's see these next coming months
okay let's do it
anything else i think that's it yeah
that's it okay
all right very good well let's check in
thank you i appreciate that good all
right so trump is checking in really
really strongly
let's go next to a trump is from dallas
texas trump is from dallas texas is next
uh yes hello hello you're on the air hey
what's up
yeah yeah you gotta be honest it's been
a weird night it's been um
i'm
are you able to get on mike in any way
you sound like you're
50 feet away or in a wind tunnel or
something wait
a little bit better now yeah that's a
little better
okay fantastic yeah um like so many
other millions of americans
i am i'm young oh yeah i'm just out of
college
um and uh
yeah you're out of college
um and i so i guess that'd be my
question to you i know when she was
first brought into office
jared sure made a lot of promises
including
negotiating peace in the middle east on
top of tackling the opioid pandemic
which uh you know which was hard to
believe at the time and
i guess i'm hoping to see some progress
there um
as far as my trump stance yet you know
honestly i think i have a uh
a route similar to many others and i
could be wrong on this
but um you know opioids
they steal your soul right i mean they
take everything from you yeah
and um remove you from that friends
family
and uh as a as absurd as it seems
um finding just a fraction of a
connection
with others you know there's there's the
lib tears there's the
you know that stuff cringy years ago but
when you're able to find just no matter
how tiny of a community it is
even if it's something where two years
ago you weren't even that politically
engaged
um when you're at such a point in your
life where
i mean it's just a binary lifestyle of
either doing drugs
or scamming money to get drugs yeah um
you kind of look towards anything you
know it kind of has me sympathetic when
i
you know you let leo remini i talk about
scientology or whatnot and um you know
so i did hear a lot of discussions
regarding like um
you know i mean aoc's tweet in
particular
dude i i was trying to excuse me i
apologize for i was gonna try to just
not the worst
guy i was gonna just try to let it go
until for a little while
what on earth are you talking about are
you talking about opioids aoc
voting trump i don't i don't know what
you're talking about right now
are you
yeah i i guess just what i i guess i was
just seeing what trump would do
uh what biden plans to do about the
opioid pandemic
wouldn't you want to research that
before deciding who to vote for or like
why did you vote for trump i'm so
confused by this call
um i i i didn't i am i i think i was
just lost and that's why i sympathized
with this cause
um and uh and that's about it that's the
oh okay wait a second so you're saying
you voted you did you just vote trump or
you voted trump in 2016.
um i was apathetic um i i mean i
all of my friends did it was um no but
i'm asking you did you vote did you vote
for
have you ever voted for trump let's see
let me take the questions one at a time
have you ever voted
in 2016 only correct you voted for trump
in 2016.
and you didn't vote for anybody this
time oh no i did not
and you're wondering what joe biden's
policy on opioids is
um that's correct okay all right very
good thank you for the call
um we figured that out uh it took just a
tiny bit of time
let's do one more trumpist then we'll
get back to other calls um chris the
trumpist chris the trumpest
hello yeah please set to do not disturb
so we don't hear those blings
okay sorry about that um pleasure i've
been watching some tim pool recently and
i've heard that trump's only legal path
to the court
is there is through the courts and i'm
curious what your thoughts
are on that uh joe biden got more votes
in enough states to get 270 electoral
votes so he will be the next president
but i've been hearing uh that he's going
to challenge it and it will go to the
house delegates
all right well let's see all right let's
see thanks for
having me on thank you very much my
pleasure wow this is a crazy day guys
this is a crazy crazy day
let me see if we can get to something a
little more normal let's go to bailey
from texas
can you guys hear me yes uh what's up
man
first of all i've been watching for a
long time thank you uh second of all
i feel like we haven't talked policy or
even discussed it in a while
i don't mean to loop back to another
caller
another caller's question but what makes
you think that
biden won't um try to
lower social security uh he did it or he
attempted it with obama wrong and i
think
he will try to do anything to pass it
through
and okay let's talk about that let's
talk about that okay hold on okay
why would joe biden what you're saying
joe but you is this are we talking when
you say lower social security do you
mean social security benefits
exactly and do you mean to people
already receiving social security or
the future benefit scale i mean to
people already receiving
okay knock no not gonna happen just
impossible not gonna happen
i mean why would he do that first of all
why would he do that and what legal path
would there be to do that
well i think he's going to try to use it
as a bartering chip with the republicans
how do you how do you do it legally how
do you do it legally
uh pass a law amend it amend what
i feel like there's a little different
options there there's not no
listen um first of all i don't know
joe biden hasn't suggested lowering
benefits on existing recipients of
social security
lowering benefits on existing recipients
is
it it would be so close to impossible
that no one is even mentioning it even
when people talk
about lowering social security benefits
they're talking about future benefits is
that something you knew
obviously that's something i considered
but my main fear
no but i know but i really want to talk
this through are you aware that the
conversation about social security
benefits
is about future benefits from people not
yet receiving
benefits did i'm just wondering if you
knew that and if you didn't it's cool
well i i knew that portion i just
automatically assumed it meant
also people currently enrolled it
doesn't okay so that's step one so
that's a key that's a key thing to
understand
secondly what has joe biden said
that makes you think he wants to lower
social security benefits
well here's the thing no politician ever
openly says
that hey we want to lower your social
security benefits no politician
says hey we don't want to cover
pre-existing conditions
but perfect closed doors both sides of
the parties
both keep trying to do that perfect so
what i'm asking is
so no both parties don't keep trying to
do that so what i'm saying is what
evidence do you have that that's
secretly something joe biden wants to do
i don't think it's something that he
wants to do but i think if mitch
mcconnell
puts a deal on the table to expand uh
health care and that's a takeaway for it
he'll do it
why would mitch mcconnell try to expand
health care
i'm saying if by i'm sorry i mean if
biden uh puts a plan forward to expand
uh healthcare and cover the medicaid
healthcare gap
yeah that mitch mcconnell will return
with counter
that listen i i think it's never gonna
happen what you're not understanding is
even republicans who talk about lowering
benefits
they typically are talking not just
about eliminating benefits
they want to move some portion over to
private industry
to give the financial industry the
ability to make money
from some of those deductions like
there's almost no one who really wants
to just
cut benefits it's a complete non-starter
politically
biden's not talking about it biden
didn't try to do it under obama
i think i think you really gotta look
into this stuff a little more and
you know you're essentially mind reading
at this point you're saying even though
no one is actually saying it nor
could it be done nor would it be
politically feasible you have the idea
that it's something biden would accept i
mean it's
i don't think we're going to get we're
not going to solve any big problems
thinking this way i don't think
that's definitely fair fair i don't
necessarily disagree with anything you
said
beautiful all right good appreciate the
call thank you so much um let's go next
to luna from new york city man it is a
full moon out there luna what's going on
luna from new york city you're on right
now
luna i can hear you in the background
but you're actually on right now
luna last opportunity you're on right
now yes i can hear you
okay you gotta mute the stream and just
listen and discord mute the stream and
listen and discover
discord yeah mute the stream and just
talk to me on discord
can you hear me yes
oh luna
luna
all right sorry luna i i wanted to talk
to you i really did
but you've got to mute the stream and
just talk to me
on discord uh let's see who
else we have here um
wow there's just there's just a lot
happening right now um
why don't we go to oh
these things are just clicking in and
out very very rapidly
let's go to william from vegas william
from las vegas euron
can you hear me yes i can
thank you for taking my call i've been
trying to get in touch with you ever
since our mayor did that crazy interview
on cnn
uh basically i have one comment slash
uh commendation and one question yep
thank you so much for the critical
thinking series on youtube i can't
uh spread that around enough thank you
thank you for doing that that's a
fantastic series
my question now
we have
people that voted for trump yes uh a
cancer in the nation
what do we do now that is going to be
something i discuss
on monday that's a huge topic what do we
do with the 70 million trumpists
and just ignoring them doesn't work
that's how
you know you barely defeat trump right
so just ignoring them doesn't work but
they are here and
something has to be done and i i want to
think about that and that'll be a big
topic on the monday show
thank you so much i look forward to it
thanks for everything that you're doing
out there hey quick question you ever go
to vesta
coffee roasters in vegas
but i will make a venture to do that now
uh
i appreciate that can you uh spell that
out for me real quick or is that
v-e-s-t-a vesta that's exactly right
v e s as in steve t
is in tom a is an apple like a granny
smith apple
great place excellent coffee recommend
the avocado toast every time i go to
vegas i go there
check it out and i'll report back thank
you all right very good we seem to be on
a bit of a delay there but we were still
able to communicate which i like
let's go next to jim from ecuador
jim from ecuador
hey how's it going good how are you i
can hear you fine
uh so i moved to ecuador from south
dakota a few months ago oh wow and i
just had a couple of questions
um i'm kind of from flyover country from
from
trump's base and we
actually passed um recreational and
medicinal marijuana and i'm a
chronically ill
person so um i just was wondering um
kind of your thoughts about that and a
bunch of other states passed it as well
yes and then also covet is kind of a big
problem here
um with people not refusing to wear
masks um i think south dakota this last
week was number one
in the world for per capita positive
testing uh
oh you're still there we have a bit of a
touch and go connection
are you asking about covet in ecuador or
south dakota
oh boy our connection i think is just
not not quite good enough right there
um to that that's a complex phone call
and i think the connection is just a
little bit a little bit short of where
it needs to be in order to be able to
carry it out
let's next go to um wait hold on i had
somebody i wanted to talk to here
there's people from all over the world
and the country right now it's crazy
let's go to lucy from atlanta lucy from
atlanta you're on the air
lucy from atlanta hey how are you yes i
can
okay awesome um well i just wanted to
say
that there's a lot going on in the live
unknown in the future but the one thing
that we do know about right now
is that we have a lot of hope for this
country
and there's a lot coming into play in
the future but
today we elected a woman of color into
one of the highest positions in our
country and
i i know i personally broke down into
tears watching
and i feel married and pride for the
first time
and i don't know how long and i just
wanted to say that because
thanks lucy i message message received
uh the can
the connection is very very touch-and-go
i really appreciate the call the
connections touch and go and i know that
there are people who think this is this
is the problem is on my end i can assure
you that this problem is not on my end
we just got we had a bunch of perfect
phone calls and then we just got a
couple that didn't go
quite so well um okay i'll take a couple
more
um let's see who else we can go to
let's try samantha from texas
samantha from texas here on the air
hello
is this samantha yes yeah
hey so uh i just kind of came on here
because uh
i noticed you're just taking girl names
tried to slide on in
okay sorry but we're not i'm alternating
uh or going two and two
obviously we're not gonna do that
because then everybody starts doing it
so we we
you know we're running a clean server
here uh we
you know we count all votes and there's
no membership
fraud or anything like that we're going
to all do it well
all right let's go to celeste from new
york city
celeste you're on
celeste from new york city you're on the
air
and celeste from new york city
all right very good okay let's now go
back let's go to
uh hold on oh my god if you guys could
only see what it was that was going on
here
let's go to matt from arizona matt from
arizona you're on
matt from arizona please unmute you are
on
how about that matt from arizona there
you are
can you hear me yes i can okay i
apologize
uh yeah great night i mean just
today uh when i woke up like
i woke up kind of late okay and seeing
that but i have one pennsylvania
right today has just been amazing so
yes uh i do have a question
sure as far as 20s i like i know you
don't
like to jump to the next thing i know 20
20
22 is the next thing but 2024 it just
jumped in my mind right now
and uh it's like if biden does maybe
just a decent job not even a
good job and then we have so many
democrat uh
candidates and then trump does run in
2024
i i don't know that scares me i don't
think trump's running in 2024 but let's
let's worry about that when we come to
it we we literally can't do anything
about that now it's not within our
control
what's within our control now is let's
have john ossoff win the runoff in
georgia you know that that's
that's actionable there's nothing
actionable about trump 2024 yet
that's true that's why i said i know you
don't like to jump to that but
it it just it did pop into my mind and
get terrified
no i understand but let's uh let's deal
with georgia first is my idea
yeah for sure so the path to a deaf
majority in the senate is
is um just on that or is or you know i
actually i actually have not looked at
senate numbers since it's been the
weekend i've just been monitoring biden
and then streaming when there's biden
news i actually don't know i would need
to look at that i'll have a report on it
monday
oh that sounds great well i mean i
appreciate everything you did but david
i've been
watching for like maybe four or five
years now so amazing
thank you so much i appreciate that
thank you very good to hear from you
guys let me get just a very quick update
from the standpoint of membership
numbers because there are some numbers
i've never seen numbers like this before
we just got another hold on 46 uh
63 additional website members
which puts us at 5 14
is my math okay and then with an
additional
hold on 23 oh no nothing a couple more
two more on twitch puts us at 5 16.
we're taking a fresh start guys
so please consider this is so simple
you go to my website joinpakman.com
you use the coupon code fresh start you
get 70
off this isn't means tested you don't
have to pass a test you don't have to
successfully explain to me why you voted
for trump as some people were
unable to do today you just use the
coupon code you sign up and beautiful
things happen okay now as i mentioned
earlier we're going to go to something a
little bit different today
i was supposed to participate in a
fundraiser today with former producer
lewis who you see here on twitch
raising money for children's hospitals i
was supposed to do it at 8pm
that's when biden spoke i wasn't able to
do it okay
i feel really bad so what i want to do
is eventually on twitch i'm going to
raid
this channel but you guys can find
louis at twitch.tv biglew49
bigleu for big lou 49
let's go over let's just see what's
happening over on lewis's stream okay
found a body on the other end you're
self-reporting
yeah i think it's you because me and lou
were in there together
he didn't kill me i don't know that was
my litmus test
hayden's scene running around okay
anyway
so that's gonna be doing it for uh
me today we've had the speech and we've
had it all
we are gonna um we are now going to raid
louis
if you're oh my god this is getting
crazy the only person i've seen running
around
it's getting crazy let's do it let's do
it if you're watching on twitch we're
going to go over there i'll be back with
you guys very soon if you're watching on
youtube or facebook go to twitch.tv
please donate to his fundraiser i didn't
get to do a fundraiser today
donate to lewis's fundraiser i'll be
watching him i'll be in the chat
i will see you guys there
you